the original 1995 mortal kombat film is
a nostalgic cult classic
and its stars remain the iconic screen
portrayals of characters like liu kang
shang tsung and sonia blade these actors
were rewarded with a rare glimpse into
the life of a hollywood performer
but where are they now already starring
as conor mcleod in highlander
another fantasy action franchise
christopher lambert was given top
billing for his supporting role as lord
raiden in the original mortal kombat
film lambert declined to appear in the
sequel
citing scheduling conflicts at the time
though he later revealed that he simply
didn't think the script was any good
he was succeeded by james remar of the
warriors and dexter fame and mortal
kombat annihilation
followed by tadabu asano in the 2021
remake
in 2020 lambert briefly returned to
voice lines for a downloadable skin
of the thunder god that bears his
likeness in the mortal kombat 11 game
while appearing in fewer blockbusters
lambert has continued to perform in film
and television productions across the
world
from the french comedy series call my
agent to the academy award-nominated
russian historical drama sobibor
american audiences most likely saw him
last as bastian moreau
in a 2019 arc of nbc's the blacklist
in addition to acting lambert co-owns a
vineyard in argentina
travels and customizes automobiles
the true lead in 1995's mortal kombat is
lou kang
portrayed by actor and martial artist
robin shue
mortal kombat was shu's first major
hollywood role but he brought with him
nine years of experience as a stunt
performer in both hollywood and hong
kong
shu also assisted fight choreographer
pat e johnson in staging some of his
martial arts battles in mortal kombat
and he accepted the offer to take the
lead as fight choreographer for the
sequel
in 1997 shu both reprised the role of
liu kang in mortal kombat annihilation
and played gobe opposite chris farley in
beverly hills ninja
shu would reunite with mortal kombat
director paul w
s anderson for his 2008 remake of death
race
he also reprised 14k his character in
death race
for the film's first two sequels death
race 2
and death race inferno portraying jen in
2009 street fighter the legend of chun
li
gave him the rare distinction of playing
both a mortal kombat character
and a street fighter character he also
had a small role in the 2006 film
adaptation of doa
dead or alive giving him the rare
fighting game movie adaptation hat trip
according to a 2020 interview with the
podcast monsters madness and magic
shu has since dedicated himself to
parenting so the
ne the last seven years i've been
basically devoted myself
to um raise my kid lyndon ashby was just
breaking into major motion pictures when
he was cast as hollywood big shock
johnny cage
just before mortal kombat he played
supporting roles opposite kevin costner
and luke perry in wyatt earp
in eight seconds respectively on mortal
kombat ashby enjoyed the freedom to
improvise and influence his
characterization
but he found shooting the fight
sequences to be a punishing experience
unhappy with the role he was offered for
the sequel ashby declined to return for
mortal kombat annihilation after mortal
kombat
he continued to appear in smaller action
films and thrillers throughout the 90s
and 2000s
but his most famous role would come in
2011
when he was cast as sheriff noah
stalinski in mtv's tv remake of teen
wolf
playing the father of one of the lead
characters ashby appeared in 88 episodes
of the hit series
all these years later however ashby
hasn't forgotten his video game days
in 2020 he recorded new voice lines and
lent his likeness to the quote
hollywood combatant skin for johnny cage
and mortal kombat 11.
kerry hiroyuki tagawa is one of those
great recognizable actors
he appeared in action films like
showdown in little tokyo
and rising sun before becoming the
villainous shang tsung in mortal kombat
while only making a brief appearance in
mortal kombat annihilation
tagawa is the one original actor to
reprise a role in the web series mortal
kombat legacy appearing in three
episodes in 2013.
he also returned to shangsung in 2019's
mortal kombat 11
as the game's canonical version of shang
tsung he is however succeeded by chen
han
in the 2021 mortal kombat film outside
of mortal kombat
tagawa has remained a constant on-screen
presence
he had a recurring role on the netflix
reboot of lost in space
and he portrayed trade minister nobusuke
tagomi
on three seasons of amazon's the man in
the high castle
tagawa has voiced frustrations over the
limited roles available to asian actors
in hollywood which has led to his long
tenure playing villains
in a 2006 documentary titled the slanted
screen
tagawa said if i'm going to choose
between a wimpy businessman and a bad
guy
i'm gonna play a bad guy because i got
balls
bridget wilson had one heck of a 1995
only two years into an exciting film
career that began opposite arnold
schwarzenegger in last action hero
wilson ended up starring in two hit
movies in one year
first she appeared as third grade
teacher veronica vaughn
in adam sandler's billy madison next she
would win the role of special forces
officer sonja blade in mortal kombat
which became available
after cameron diaz hot off her comedy
debut in the mask
broke her risk training for the film
wilson continued to appear in multiple
movies a year
including four feature films in 1997
which left no room in her schedule for
mortal kombat annihilation
or so she claimed however wilson would
return to voice the classic
mk movie sonia blade skin for mortal
kombat 11.
since 2008 wilson has withdrawn from the
busy life of a hollywood actor to pursue
another of her lifelong dreams
being a full-time parent and homemaker
following a prosperous modeling career
brooklyn actress talisa soto
already had a prominent role in the
blockbuster action film licensed to kill
before becoming outworlds princess
katana in mortal kombat
after the video game adaptation soto
found herself cast in a string of
infamously bad films
such as mortal kombat annihilation the
direct-to-video adaptation of the pulpy
horror comic vampirella
in 2002's ballistic x versus sever
since then she made one more credited
acting appearance in 2009 with remission
written and directed by her
brother-in-law peter bratt
soto has been out of public life for
over a decade and has given few
interviews
but she can often be seen walking the
red carpet at premieres and award shows
with her husband
actor benjamin bratt with whom she has
two children
in the mortal kombat movie english actor
trevor goddard portrayed the smirking
mercenary kano with an australian accent
that was later adopted in the game
series
so what's the origin behind that voice
well goddard spent years in hollywood
claiming to have been a boxer from perth
australia
which was according to the lakeland
ledger a total invention
those rare interviews with goddard that
can be found online still cling to this
fiction
leaving very little information behind
about his real life
while his film career never took off
goddard found a home on the cbs drama
jag
as lieutenant commander mike brumby he
appeared in 42 episodes of the series
alongside his friend catherine bell whom
he met on the set of the low budget
action film men of war in 1994.
sadly goddard died in 2003 at the age of
40 from a drug overdose
his final feature film roll which hit
screens a month later was grapple
a pirate aboard the titular vessel and
pirates of the caribbean the curse of
the black pearl
one of the most iconic characters from
the mortal kombat video game series
scorpion had a minor role in the
original film where he was all but
silent
save for his famous taunt get over here
since his only purpose in the film was
to fight the role was filmed by stunt
actor chris casamassa who also doubled
as the onset trainer for his on-screen
opponent
johnny cage actor lyndon ashby casamassa
reprised scorpion in mortal kombat
annihilation and in four episodes of the
short-lived syndicated television series
mortal kombat conquest
other highlights of his stunned career
include doubling as the caped crusader
for george clooney in 1997's batman and
robin
and coordinating on blade the following
year he is now
president and ceo of red dragon karate a
school founded in 1965 by his father
louis d casamassa he is also the head
instructor at the glendora california
location
the man under sub-zero's mask was french
martial artist
dancer and personal trainer francois
petit petit was involved in the film
long before the rest of the cast
working to recruit more stunned
performers when a suitable actor
couldn't be found to play sub-zero
the role fell to petit though his on-set
responsibilities led to a reduction of
the part
in addition to his work staging the
action petit was also kari hiroyuki
tagawa's fight trainer
petit has personally trained huge stars
throughout his career
including arnold schwarzenegger and
dwayne johnson he served on the wwf
medical staff in the 90s and can be seen
tending to mick foley after the
wrestler's now famous 16-foot fall in
the quote
hell in the cell match had 1998's king
of the ring event
while no longer active in hollywood
petite has worked as a dance
choreographer consultant as recently as
2020.
master keith cook hirobayashi was
already a celebrated martial arts
competitor before he began taking roles
in hollywood action movies
in 1990 he appeared opposite martial
arts legend cynthia rothrock
in the two back-to-back films chyna
o'brien and chyna o'brien too
after initial test screenings for mortal
kombat came back with one prevailing
request
quote more fights cook was brought in to
participate in one of the added action
sequences
as reptile cook's decades of experience
made him a great dance partner for rob
and shoes lou kay
cook was invited back in 1997 for a
fighting and speaking role as the new
sub-zero in mortal kombat annihilation
and he would also join robin shu in
beverly hills ninja that same year
while he no longer appears in films he
is the owner and head instructor of
keith cook
studios in brentwood california where
he's trained several hollywood stars in
preparation for athletically demanding
roles
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
mortal kombat are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you